et en marge de cette conférence de paris
sur la libye rencontre ce midi au quai
d'orsay entre les ministres russe et
français des affaires étrangères est
désarmé sergueï lavrov et sergueï
choïgou rencontre ce midi leurs
homologues jean yves le drian et
florence parly on retrouve tout de suite
katia pique nique sur place
à katia quel est l'objectif de cette
rencontre au sommet
oui bien à grégory cette réunion du
conseil de coopération franco-russe
portera sur les questions de sécurité et
la prévention des incidents militaires
selon un communiqué des ministres
français elle sera centrée sur la
dimension politique et militaire de
crise régionale et internationale je
rappelle que l'origine de ce conseil
remonte à 2002 sur l'initiative des
présidents jacques chirac et vladimir
poutine mais les discussions s'étaient
interrompus en 2014 à cause de la crise
ukrainienne le dialogue à ce sujet a été
rétablie en 2019 à l'initiative
d'emmanuel macro et de vladimir poutine
il y a donc bien une volonté de
renforcer la coopération franco russe
sur les questions de sécurité européenne
et mondiale c'est ainsi que le ministre
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
et le ministre de la défense sergueï
choïgou pardon sont actuellement reçus
par le ministre des affaires étrangères
jean yves le drian et la ministre des
armées florence parly alors que va-t-il
être dit aujourd'hui et bien on imagine
bien sûr que les ministres aborderont la
question de la sécurité au sahel après
les tensions survenues sur le terrain et
des reproches formulés par la france à
moscou il sera aussi question de
l'afghanistan de la libye et puis un
sujet majeur l'ukraine sergueï lavrov a
promis une conversation très sérieuse à
ce sujet regrettant la connivence de la
france avec le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky plus généralement il
sera bien sûr question de stabilité
européenne de non prolifération des
armements d'armes man dans l'espace et
puis sur la table également la
coopération entre les pays européens et
la russie au sujet du dossier du
programme nucléaire iranien donc pour le
moment comme je le disais l'exécution au
lieu et nous reparlerons de la teneur de
celle ci plus tard dans la journée merci
katia technique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc du ministère
français des affaires étrangères au quai
d'orsay à paris merci également à didier
mulot qui vous accompagnent derrière la
caméra